foreign
we're back
um so a few I guess it's a month ago now
by the time this episode's out
um
I launched an episode with my friend Sal
de Stefano from San Jose California he's
part of the Mind pump group
um one of the one of my most important
interviews I've ever done because I left
that interview and I know you all have
benefited from it I've heard the
feedback it's just been phenomenal
but selfishly I changed how I do my life
on the back end of that interview I said
some things out loud to somebody else
I've never said before I've never talked
about my struggles with with disordered
eating I've never talked about
um I've worked out for 30 years and I
still have always thought I'm screwing
this thing up turns out I was
um my I implemented some things right
when I got home that have had drastic
changes in my life and one of the most
common questions I get from you all is
cool deloni you have an hour every
morning
um to do this long workout and you get
all your stuff in
I don't have that time I've got three
little kids I'm an over the road trucker
I'm a surgeon I just don't have an hour
like whatever it is and so I reached out
to Sal and the Gang and said hey
you guys have something that I can just
tell everybody about and one of the guys
Adam one of my pump guys said hang on
just hang on and then all of a sudden
dude they launched naps 15 which I'm
super jazzed about I've actually been
working on it and so listen this is
important this is not a advertisement
they didn't pay me I called them okay
um there's no hookup here this is simply
me telling you guys that doing the Mind
pump maps program helped me to help me
become a better dad help me become a
better husband to help me become a
better employee here help me become a
better Citizen and I'm an advocate of
their work there is no money being
exchanged here I'm not making a cent off
of this conversation what I do what I
what I'm committed to is getting you all
things that are going to help you have
better lives and so I called Sal and
said hey would you be on the show talk
about this new program tell everybody
all about it because he's smarter than
me and way smarter than me with this
stuff and I wanted to give you guys a
ringside seat to this new thing that
just hit the marketplace Sal you there
I'm here John what's up homie how we
doing
I'm doing good man thanks for having me
on I appreciate the kind words you got
it uh do I sound bigger and stronger
as usual yes yes I'm hoping you can hear
my musculature
um how are things I heard y'all at earth
earthquake y'all are all good
we did we had actually in the middle of
a podcast we had a a guest come in from
out of out of state so it was his first
time experiencing an earthquake scared
him a little bit did y'all uh I could
just imagine the Mind pump dude y'all
just all held hands and flexed real hard
and the Earth just stood still is that
how that happened
[Laughter]
awesome okay so since we've um last been
in touch uh since we last we're together
in California
I have to tell you man the maps anabolic
has been transformative for me
um it's been it's been nothing short of
magic and I've worked out my whole life
um it's very special and I can tell the
thoughtful and scientific way you'll put
this thing together this isn't just a
cobble together email and then y'all got
a new thing out that's going to help the
really busy single moms and the cops who
don't have much time it's going to help
what I consider regular human beings
um talk about what you just put out and
talk about the benefits and everything
about it yeah absolutely
um so the biggest challenge by far when
it comes to fitness and exercise for
most people okay so now I'm talking to
the average person is really about
consistency and and consistency is the
biggest challenge lots of people get
started with workouts but it's very hard
to do it on a consistent month after
month year after year basis and one
thing that we figured out as trainers
you know we trained everyday regular
people for over two decades was that
people were actually more consistent if
you gave them short workouts to do every
day versus longer workouts to do less
frequently so for example
instead of doing two let's say one hour
workouts a week
um 15 minutes every single day people
just found it easier to be consistent
it's easier to find the time
it's uh you get the ball rolling you
practice this good relationship with
exercise on a regular basis you develop
this better relationship faster as a
result of that you don't beat yourself
up in the workout which that tends to be
a more challenging relationship to build
is like pain that you feel from working
out well 15 minutes you tend to feel a
little less pain but it's also just uh
as effective a lot of people think well
is this going to be as effective as you
know going to the gym a few days a week
yes it is it's uh the same amount of
volume same amount of reps you're just
breaking it up on a on a daily basis and
when it comes to strength training in
particular all you need to do is send
the signal to your body so that it can
change so the the actual progress that
your body makes with the workout is not
in the workout it's the signaling
process and then it's afterwards when
your body's actually starting to adapt
and change and get stronger and then of
course from that process you get a
faster metabolism makes it easier for to
get lean and all that stuff so what we
did is we put together a workout program
that's 15 minutes today it uses a
suspension trainer and a pair of
dumbbells so you can literally hang the
suspension trainer in your in your
doorway like a TRX kind of thing
exactly so TRX would be the brand name
of what a suspension trainer right okay
okay and you just you just jump on there
you do two or three exercises and the
workouts are all mapped out for you and
planned with demos and the whole deal
and um and you work out and what we're
finding is exactly what we found when we
train clients which is and this is just
people now are messaging us saying this
is the most consistent I've ever been
with workouts my body's changing I
didn't realize that I could get results
doing you know something like this and
it's um it's a game changer and again if
you could solve the consistency issue
you've solved the fitness problem and uh
that's what we're attempting to do with
this and it's it's working out pretty
well well let me add another layer to it
um
I'm not proud of this but I'm somebody
for years who has
if I've got 40 minutes in the morning
and
um my son who's 12 is getting up to go
to school
one day a week we go to breakfast
together but the other days a week I
could be sitting upstairs having
breakfast with my son listening to him
talk about his day how are things going
and I'm always in the basement at the in
the gym working out because I'm going to
get my 45 or 50 minutes in and so
um you sent me this right as right
before it launched and I've been
utilizing it at home and it just so
happened a month after I got home from
California I signed up and uh we mapped
out and I'm working on another big book
I've hit the road follows my busy travel
schedule for Live Events I'm all over
the place
and suddenly
I don't have the time and so here's what
this thing has given me the consistency
was was less of an issue and I know
that's harder for for what I would say
average people but people who aren't
psychotic like I am
but this has given me time back with my
family Sal and it's given me it's
helping me be a better husband and a
better dad because in this wild season
I'm in I don't have an hour that doesn't
come at the cost of something that is
probably more important existentially
and so I want to say thank you for
giving me a program I'm still sweating
and I'm still I'm making it as hard as I
can in that 15-20 minutes and I'm using
it but it's given me
the most precious resource I have on the
planet it's not renewable which is time
especially with my little ones man so
thank you for putting this out there
what are you hearing from from people
who use this as they're coming back what
are you hearing well there's two two
types of people that'll typically that
have been messaging us the first one is
the person that does have the challenges
with consistency and they're sending us
emails saying this is I I've never been
this consistent it feels like I'm
developing a behavior this is definitely
something I can continue long term and
then we have the the skeptical Advanced
you know person who's been working out
for a long time who didn't think that
their body would respond training in
this particular way and and I'd like to
for those people I'd like to point to
the data that you we have on Olympic
weightlifters and strength athletes I
mean the Soviets back in the day figured
this out that short frequent workouts
were more effective than long any
frequent workouts infrequent I should
say workouts when it came to getting the
body to progress and again I want to
hammer this home it's not the how many
calories you burn in the workout it's
not it's not the workout itself that's
giving you the value it's what what it
does to your body how it signals that
adaptation process so so that's how we
probably around the world that's how all
workouts should be programmed really bad
workouts are written in ways to make you
feel sore and like it's really hard and
you might get results initially and then
you figure out and then you can't figure
out why your body plateaued it's because
they don't focus on the adaptation
process it's all about just making you
feel like you're getting a good workout
in the workout itself we don't write
programs that way you know we like I
said we train people people for a long
time and for us it's all about results
and then you said one more thing John
I'd like to add which is you know and
this is uh such a key thing you don't
people most people don't live to work
out I mean you could be a fitness
fanatic and it could be your your job I
guess but most people want to work out
to live better that's really what it
should be all about and that's how you
develop that long term forever
relationship is do my workouts give me
more time do they improve the quality of
my life do I have more energy so it's
really about improving the quality of
your life not living to work out so
that's what this program is really all
about I love it and I'll speak to those
folks who are
already go to the gym a lot and they
they kind of like the old way of doing
work like I'm the first gen in the last
out I was here longer than anybody else
when and now we all realize well golf
clap do congratulations for Galatians
like did you get the job done and how
effective were you I don't care how long
you sat there so some of us get our um
our self-esteem boosted a little bit by
how long we're in the gym or whatever I
will speak to
um a this program's written in a way
that I can
I can modulate up if I need it to be a
little more aggressive or if I just need
to get to to blow it out a bit I can I
can modulate it up I can no one's
stopping me from staying an extra five
or ten minutes
and if I do it right then I follow the
clock I leave I can I can believe pretty
gassed right it's it's I'm not I don't
feel like I'm skimping on anything and
in fact
um there's been a couple of times the
last few weeks when I would have just
skipped I would have skipped and I would
have gone to work and knocked it out and
uh I would have gone to work and just
skipped for the day and I went ahead
downstairs and knocked it out so
um man oh man oh man okay so where do
people go get this
um wait let's back up tell them about
real quick tell them about your the maps
architecture like what is the program
what is it which ones exist and then
tell them where they can go get this
Maps 15 the new program yeah yeah so
Maps is an acronym that stands for
muscular adaptation programming system
and all of our programs we kind of
create this Avatar and we try to write
workout programs that really are the
most effective that require the least
amount of work to produce the most
amount of results that's really what
it's all about um you know if if you
need to dig a hole why use a spoon when
you can use a shovel right so trying to
make them just as effective as possible
with the amount of time that people will
spend doing them so we have a lot of
maps programs we have some that are
extremely Advanced like if you're like a
competitive level body builder or power
lifter or you do obstacle course racing
and then we have programs for total
beginners we have programs like Maps 15
which is really about tackling that
consistency issue which we think Maps 15
is going to be the one that and it's
already turning out to be the most
popular program that we've ever uh
created that's right all of these
programs you can find them at
mapsfitnessproducts.com and then you can
see the name and you you could kind of
hover over and watch the videos and kind
of get the explanation as to what the
program's about and kind of figure out
which one's for you and there's a chat
function there where you can ask
somebody if you really need help on you
know figuring out because the right
workout will do the best for the right
person so you want to find the right one
for you always that's fantastic well
um
on behalf of just regular moms and dads
I want to thank you thank you and your
whole team for putting this together for
putting it out there I want to thank you
personally for your time this morning
thank you for the impact you've had on
my on my family and for putting the
stuff in a way that even a guy who
thought he knew everything about it has
I've had a lot to learn and a lot to
unlearn really and thank you for the
continued message you guys are putting
out into the world to reshape the re
retake the health and fitness industry
man and make it digestible and make it
actually applicable to people who are
hurting out there I'm really grateful
for the work you and your gang are doing
I appreciate that John and I do want to
add uh one thing is um it's quite
humbling to meet somebody like you I
mean what you said in the beginning is
100 true this is not a paid sponsorship
or advertising you called us
and just really liked what we did and
wanted us on your show and uh I really
don't I've never really met anybody
uh quite like that um so I appreciate
you're very genuine and honest um and
that's just for your audience to know
like this guy's he's the real deal
um he really cares about people and and
if you know he finds value he wants to
pay people back so you're uh you've made
impacts on us too John so I appreciate
it I'm grateful my brother
um stay in school don't do drugs all
that stuff and give Justin a hug because
he needs one for sure for sure man uh
hey I appreciate you all much and um
Everybody Maps 15 go to maps
fitnessproducts.com you can go to mind
pump and scroll down and find it Maps
15. if you are stressed if you are busy
if you are trying to figure out dude I
want to get into this Weight Workout
thing that delony's always talking about
I don't know how to do it I don't even
know where to start
um I can't think of a better place to
send you
um go to Maps 15 again
no partnership here no money is
exchanging hands this is me telling you
this has impacted me and my family and I
know it will positively impact you and
yours